Où est Félicie ?
Depuis que je suis toute petite , je ne pense qu'à danser.
Si on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir, tu deviendras la meilleure de toutes les danseuses et moi le plus grand inventeur de tous les temps !
Vous êtes la grâce à votre ténacité et à votre talent.
Vous avez toutes travaillé dur.
Sauf vous !
Chaque jour, l'une d'entre vous sera éliminée.
Tu n'as qu'une adversaire : Camille.
Sa technique est parfaite.
Tendu, plié !
Demain matin, entraînement à cinq heures.
Cinq heures du matin?
Tiens bien l'équili... *chute*
Alors je l'aurai jamais ce rôle ?!
Si tu l'auras.
Tu as dans le cœur quelque chose qu'elle n'aura jamais
La passion !
Y'a un garçon il est beau gosse !
il dit que je vais devenir une étoile.
C'est ce que je t'ai toujours dis !
Mais lui il est trop intense !
Il ne faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves !
Danse avec tout ton cœur.
Je trouve que... que t'es géniale.
Tu fais quoi là? *gênée*
Euh... *se rattrape* Je m'étire tu voix regarde ça y est !
Ou est Félicie ?
Depuis que je suis toute petite je ne pense qu'à danser.
Si on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir, tu deviendras la meilleur de toutes les danseuses et moi le plus grand inventeur de tous les temps !
Ouh oh, non non non *rire génant*
T'as un plan ? Un plan infaillible !
Bye bye! *salut*
Quoi ?!
Bienvenue à Paris princesse !
Eurk.. *dégoût* C'est quand la dernière fois que tu t'es laver les dents?
Ça y est ! Je suis danseuse, à l'opéra!
Enfin, je suis élève pour l'instant.
Vous êtes la grâce à votre ténacité et à votre talent.
Sauf vous !
Dés demain nous commencerons les auditions.
Chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera éliminée
Tu n'a qu'une adversaires.. Camille
Sa technique est parfaite !
Tendu, plié !
Et le mot perdre ne fait pas partie de son vocabulaire.
Demain matin entraînement à 5 heures.
5 heures du matin ?!
Moi je suis une étoile.
Alors que toi tu ne brilleras jamais... !
Tu dois apprendre à maîtriser ton vertige.
Alors je l'aurai jamais ce rôle ?
Si tu l'auras, tu as dans le cœur
quelque chose qu'elle n'aura jamais !
La passion !
Y'a un garçon il est beau gosse !
Il dit que je vais devenir une étoile.
C'est ce que je t'ai toujours dis !
Danse, avec tout ton cœur.
Oh oh oh aaaaaah *chute*
Tu fait de la danse ou du kung-fu ? *rire*
Oh t'es tellement drôle ! *blasé*
Victor ! Où est Félicie ?
Une école de danse à Paris !
L'Opéra de Paris.
Félicie je sais que tu rêve de devenir danseuse mais les rêves ne se réalisent pas !
Ce soir, on s'échappe
Tu deviendras une grande étoile ! Et moi je deviendrais le plus grand inventeur de tout les temps !
T'as un plan ? Un plan infaillible !
Voici mes ailes de poulet ! Ressemblant non ?!
Mais t'es bête ou quoi ?! Les poulets ça ne vooooole pas !
Bien sur que si ça vole !
*chute du poulet*
Revenez ici !
il faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves !